pick a problem any problem and do
something about it because to somebody
who's hurting something is everything
the path to making money is to solving
problems what I do in a given day is I
have a set of problems that need to be
solved and I started the most important
and work my way down rise and shine it's
an espresso time what's up believe
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
solve problems over to you Oprah Winfrey
also if you want to hear what Oprah and
other successful entrepreneurs has to
say about building confidence check out
my 250 for confidence series I have paid
attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you real work
is to figure out where your power base
is every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a 30 second to five minute
video for free every morning to help you
build unstoppable confidence the link is
in the description
[Music]
you build a legacy not from one thing
but from everything I remember when I
just opened my school in 2007 I came
back and I had the great joy of sitting
in Maya Angelou stable she hadn't been
able to attend the opening in South
Africa and I said to her Oh Maya the
Oprah Winfrey Leadership Academy that's
gonna be my greatest legacy I remember
she was standing at the counter making
biscuits and she turned she put the
dough down and she looked at me and she
said you have no idea what your legacy
will be this excuse me I just opened
this school and these girls and it's
gonna be and she said you have no idea
what your legacy will be because your
legacy is every life you touch every
life you touch
that changed me and it's true you can't
personally stop anybody from walking
into school with an assault rifle nor
can you see Cal handedly ensure that the
rights that your mother's and your
grandmother's fought so hard for will be
preserved for the daughters that you may
someday have and it'll take more than
you alone to pull 40 million Americans
out of poverty but who will you be if
you don't care enough to try and what
mountains could we move I think what
gridlock could we eradicate if we were
to join forces and work together and
service of something greater than
ourselves you know my deepest
satisfaction and my biggest rewards have
come from exactly that pick a problem
any problem and do something about it
because to somebody who's hurting
something is everything you have the
ability to help people and I'm a firm
believer that if you have the ability
you have the responsibility if you can
then you must this is what entrepreneurs
do we see big problems we get frustrated
with them we want to solve them we don't
just sit around complain like everybody
else does we have to find a solution for
it we want to make it better for
ourselves and better for the people
around us as well that's the difference
between entrepreneurs and everybody else
the path to making money is to solving
problems if you want to make a lot of
money you have to solve a problem right
solve a big problem you want to make
money quickly solve that big problem
quickly and so I think it's something
that people can resonate with but you
have to tie it in to your purpose in
your pain the reason why I love helping
entrepreneurs so much is because I
struggled so much being an entrepreneur
as much as I lean in on a positive and
say I love entrepreneurs because we're
gonna solve all the world's major
problems because we don't complain
because we tackle the impossible and we
make the world better that's all true
but the real reason why I love
entrepreneurs so much and helping is
because I struggled so much myself as an
entrepreneur and just feeling that lack
of self-worth that lack of confidence I
feeling like I'm not good enough that
I'm putting all this effort in and I'm
not getting any kind of results that has
never happened before in my life where
we put in work and you get results here
was putting in tons of work and getting
zero results that's how I can resonate
with
watching cuz I'm that was me I still to
this day resonate more with the people
who are struggling to buy a Big Mac meal
at McDonald's then I do the people
buying the fancy cars and condos even
though I live more in that world now I
still relate better to the startup into
the grind to the hustling the pain
because that's actually my story it's a
world that my son won't really know and
so I think if you can tap into the deep
pain that you have inside you wherever
that came from and then not just live in
that pain and suffer forever but turn it
into how can I use this pain to serve
because in that service you are solving
a problem for other people and whether
you choose to help five people ten
people have a have a little impact on
the people closest to you or whether you
go on a big mission to solve the problem
for the world like I'm trying to do
either path is okay I'm gonna give you
three ways on how to do it the first one
is to remember your big why the big
why's the missions big why is what
you're trying to accomplish why why why
why why why does this mean so much to
you
for me it's helping entrepreneurs
believe in themselves I want to solve
the world's biggest problem I think we
could have already solved cancer by now
but the woman who would have solved
cancer is a manager an accounting firm
instead of actually going down that
biology path because her parents believe
in her because she didn't believe in
herself because she never took an
interest in biology for whatever reason
a whole source of reasons but she could
have done this great thing and instead
she's in a job that she doesn't like so
remembering that big mission on a daily
basis helps keep you motivated to keep
going number two remember your little
why sometimes the big why's too big
sometimes a big wise too
all-encompassing you feel like you can't
do it I'm trying to solve the world's
biggest problem I'm trying to solve a
problem that will never be solved
in my lifetime it will not be solved and
yet I wake up every day and I try to go
solve it Antti in the ocean with a cup
every time that's how I'm trying to do
one will never empty the ocean so
sometimes I can be overwhelming and you
feel like you can't do it and you're not
good enough and who are you to go off
and do this big thing in that case
remember the little why the little why's
are all the individual people that you
have helped so whenever I get worried
that I can't go off and do the thing
that I'm trying to do solve the world's
biggest problem I just think to the
people who I have helped I think about
Alex and Lily I think about the people
I've met through people buying the book
and people messaging me through YouTube
and the one-on-ones I've had with people
around the world through the events that
I've gone
I know that I've touched those people it
may not seem logical or easy for me to
do the big mission but I know that I've
helped those people that have come in
touch with and that can give you the
motivation to keep going knowing that
you've helped at least one person and at
least another person another person and
reminding yourself of those individual
people so it brings it home as opposed
to just thinking this big mass problem
this faceless problem I think can really
help and number three is just to start
making money you know as you start
making money as you start building
momentum for your business it starts to
breathe more momentum right one of the
hardest things to do is being
entrepreneur and not be making any money
it's really hard to keep going when you
just keep putting in tons of work and
don't see money coming in and it's not
that money is the only purpose you're
trying to do something big and Noble but
you need to make money in the process
too and the faster you start making
money the faster you'll be able to have
more confidence and keep building your
business and so what I look for is if
you're if your purpose comes from your
pain and you've solved it for yourself
how you make money is you start shortcut
in that path for other people so
whatever your pain was so for me you
know struggling entrepreneurship and
taking however many years to get out of
it and and solve it and fix it and then
taking that path if it took you 10 years
to figure out the solution to your pain
or three years you can condense that
down to four people if you could take
that thing that took you through the ten
years to learn and you can dense it down
into thirty days because there's a guy
now because there's you because you were
figuring all out for yourself you were
stumbling around and not sure of the
path and super confused but now you can
be the guide for other people you can
tell them the step-by-step exercises on
what to do and you can make money doing
that
whether that's making YouTube videos
like this and it's step by step whether
it's becoming an author making your own
book whether that's selling you know
your own course online whether it's a
video course or eCourse there's lots of
ways to be able to do it or thinking
what is the most effective way to
condense the process of becoming what
you've become from where you were and
then guiding people along that journey
the thing that you wish that you had I
wish that I had this YouTube channel
when I was 19 and struggling in my
business create the thing you wish you
had when you were the person in that
hole and then started charging for it
start making money for it start building
momentum so be the new life
into what you're doing build a team go
solve even bigger problems that's when
you find ultimate satisfaction if you
have the ability to help people then
it's your responsibility to do so if you
can then you must now we've got a really
special bonus clip I think you guys are
going to enjoy but before that question
today I want to know what is the big
problem that you are trying to solve if
you could snap your fingers and the
world looks a different way how would it
look what is that issue that you are
trying to tackle yourself leave it down
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
[Music]
we are not a company that normally China
corn we call ourselves accompanied
running a platform a company that is
running an ecosystem we are almost
everywhere people say Jack you know you
are in the b2b and b2c and you're
calling CTV on a finance and online
payment logistic cloud computing you are
everywhere
not because we're greedy not because we
want to do it because we have to do it
if we cannot if we do not to do it
China ecommerce in the years will
collapse
I remember nine years ago when I started
that alley pay people say Jeff don't
touch the financing sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison and I we
taught our self if we don't do it the
China ecommerce were always like like a
chat room everybody said it's a good
thing and I don't pay you don't get the
things so I say well put me in the
prison let's make a shirt that Ali pay
the payment solution works and people
said the payment solution is such a
stupid idea it's an escrow service I pay
you hold the money and you get the
things you pay the money if you don't
get the things you want return the money
they say it's a stupid product and I say
as long as to solve the problem
I like stupid things you know let's make
stupid things smart keep on improving
every day my I like to say my management
style is problem solver and chief and so
what I do in a given day is I have a set
of problems that need to be solved and I
started the most important and work my
way down and for the problems I don't
have time for somebody else gets to
solve them now if somebody's already
solving another problem of solving a
problem I don't need to get involved if
the problem is getting solved but you
know people go wow so your days just
full of problems I'm like yeah I've got
a lot of problems but but it's sort of
like how a math professor thinks of
problems right is that think of a great
math professor who has no math problems
to solve
he's a very sad man
nah and so that's very much how I look
at it solving problems is a you know
every problem is an opportunity for
innovating and being creative and
finding something new and that's what I
love to do and I do it every day
we believe that software is at a stage
where you know software increasingly is
playing a more and more critical role in
solving things which it didn't before
okay so to me when I look at cars people
spend an inordinate amount of time in
cars these are resources which are very
poorly utilized right now as we speak
you know you can look outside and you
can see all the cars which are proud of
their cars we rented we rented to get
here is just sitting in the parking
stripes so they can't use less than 10%
so we see these problems and we see okay
can we swallow that scale and just
computing play a part in it software and
computer science and while the effort
may seem ambitious or crazy you know we
take a very disciplined approach inside
right you know so those are taught
through like businesses which we are
building and it's just to be able to
take a long term view but we run them in
a very disciplined way our research can
be longer term and we do that precisely
in research you know when we take
research projects like Google a tab or a
core research we never know whether some
of them even makes viable business
applications but we want to push the
technology at times because you don't
know what's possible on the other side
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that people with
passion
now one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
rows of success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business
check the link in description for
details